Apple is the most important company in
the music industry from the ipod to
itunes to beats to the iPhone Apple has
reinvented the way we listen to music as
many times as you can think of and this
year they tried to do it again Apple
music is a brand new app that's coming
june thirtieth two more platforms than
you might think for your normal apple
product it's coming to mac and iOS but
also to pc and android and apple TV it's
going to be everywhere and there are
three basic parts of this app one is
essentially itunes but the whole library
you can have your local library of all
the songs you've bought and added to
itunes anyway but you can also access
the whole itunes library for ten dollars
a month even stream any song you want on
demand and there are these curated
playlists for you full of new music that
you might not have heard and music that
Apple think she'll like and they're all
human curated there's no algorithms here
just people picking music you like so
that's one part the second part is a
global single radio station it's DJed by
three different people in three
different places New York LA and London
and it's designed to be what Apple loves
about music which is that everybody's
listening to the same things and sort of
sharing this experience so the third
thing is what I have the least faith in
it's called Kinect and it's essentially
a social network around musicians so if
you're an artist new or old you can have
a page you can upload photos you can
upload behind-the-scenes videos you can
upload your new songs you can just talk
to fans and it's designed to be a way to
connect people who love music with
people who make music and Apple has all
the scale to do this but what they don't
have is any history of making good
social networks connected sort of a mix
of MySpace and apples ping which really
didn't work very well before but this is
unlike anything Apple has done since the
beginning of iTunes it's a huge sweeping
play to bring the whole music industry
back into the Apple banner iTunes it's
going to look different your app is
going to look different the whole
service is going to look different and
this according to Apple is what the
music is
is going to look like for the next day